weil wir also man muss schon sagen so
eine flex aber bei mir läuft schon hart
so mach dir mal an dann an gelenken
linke sollten wir meine mama verarschen
ich schicke mal ein foto frey wir haben
wir eine uwe kauss 6000 euro wollte ich
nur sagen mal gucken was zurückkommt
okay ich glaube 20.000 was machst du mir
das game nach ziemlich klein
ich hatte jetzt gedacht dass größer da
habe ich mich nämlich am meisten drauf
gefreut
das trage ich öfter jetzt in dem video
sven das geil aussieht naja kann man mal
direkt zum thema auch ne wir müssen noch
einen anfang machen ja mach weist eine
tosca und herzlich willkommen bei einem
neuen video
kennst du schon den deb das ist also ein
ewf halt ne denn der ist halt auch mit
trent manchmal dann wenn magna okay
leute ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut
ich darf euch ganz herzlich begrüßen zu
einem neuen video und zwar habe ich mal
wieder bei uns bestellt auf euren wunsch
ich habe irgendwann mal den kommentar
gelesen alex bei bosch gibt es auch
einst auf produkte also uhren ketten
ringe habe ich den ring habe ich glaube
ich gar nicht bestellt
doch ich an insgesamt fünf ice auf
produkte bestellt die a male zwischen 2
und 12 euro oder so gekostet jetzt
nichts teures so aber es gab auch nichts
neues also ich habe wirklich das beste
rausgesucht und ist ja ganz witzig meine
dieser icao trend ist er gar zum voll im
trend
doch das sind und wir haben letztens
irgendwann schon mal so echte gold
produkte getestet schaut euch das video
sehr gerne an und heute machen wir
weiter mit eis taut produkten ich muss
aber sagen ich freue mich deutlich mehr
jetzt auf dieses video als auch das gold
video weil das war irgendwie nicht ganz
so interessant fand ich wollen uns mal
ganz kurz die sache dann schon nicht
bestellt habe ich musste sagen nein nein
oder haben wir der ist auch trainiert
schon wieder vorbei
schauen sie direkt mal rein als erstes
habe ich gekauft eine antwort steilen 14
k gold plate watch also sowas hier halt
und muss ich sagen auf dem foto sieht
doch schon nice aus und das alles ohne
uhr kostet 15 mit und also thema uhren
bin ich raus kenne mir nicht so gut aus
ich habe auch keine uhr
aber ich hab mal so gehört seiner eis
taut watch kostet schon mal schnell 50
kehlen
ich will einfach mal gespannt wie das
gleich an meinem arm aussieht ob das
einfach kacke aussieht oder ob mann ob
das hochwertig aus wie bei unterschätzen
die macht von busch das ding ist das
heftigste also gibt's nicht mehr länger
als ausverkauft scheiße was machen wir
jetzt
der gips ich mache da habe ich aber
glück dass ich noch zugeschlagen haben
warte mal ich kann es euch jetzt nur
hier zeigen wir haben hier ganz
kleinlaut länger da oben hat auch nur
drei euro kostet jugend hat irgendwie
gedacht das ist ein riesending ist es
glaube ich nicht und dann haben wir noch
eine uhr die zeigt euch noch ganz
schnell und eine stadt mit dem auspacken
ach so ja okay und dann habe ich noch
diese uhr hier gekauft funkelt funkel
starke sieht man dass das punkte und
hielt mal witzig mal okay naja unterhalt
noch andere sachen wir packen das jetzt
einfach mal aus und dann schauen wir mal
mit soll ich anfangen hier mit jemand
die kleinst du hast sogar recht wir
haben hier tatsächlich in eis taut
bringen im goldring mit eis drauf
so geht man auch mit seinen sachen
umwelt sind aber das ist mir bei dem
golf video auch schon aufgefallen
man muss ja sagen die sind immer gut
eingepackt hier schönen so papier kann
nichts mehr passieren
nicht schlecht weißt du was wir machen
können das wäre doch witzig ich gehe mit
versteckter kamera zusammen
juwelier und so weit ist das denn wert
hier aber ich darf in einer sekunde
erkennt meinste auf jeden fall muss
nämlich nicht um so eine lupe und so ich
glaube das erkennt man sofort ich sag
ich hab den hier draußen gefunden was
kostenstruktur das waren hier sieht man
auf der kamera das ist so glitzert und
funkelt wenn man das so zum licht hält
finde ich das ist schon nicht schlecht
also natürlich jetzt nicht so heftig wie
schon gesagt ich kenne mich damit nicht
ausüben lässt sich erkennen ob das real
oder fake ist so leute bei 5.000
leichter macht das mit dem juwelier will
schon mal wir haben ja noch mehr sachen
und dann zeigt dem vielleicht auch mal
die uhr oder irgendwas ihr seid ihr
schreibt in die kommentare welches
produkte ich den zeigen soll
und mal gucken was er sagt wo man was
natürlich auch ganz wichtig ist wir
lassen aber die sachen an während wir
weiter auspacken war weiter hier möglich
oder dass wir gut aus cook wieder super
eingepackt kann nichts mit passieren ja
eingeschweißt nicht kommen nicht gibt
ihr mal dieses gerät hier eine art von
durch aber ich muss sagen das sieht
nicht mal so habe ich ja auch gesagt und
das hat drei euro gekostet jetzt also
dieses produzieren also man muss schon
sagen so eine flex aber bei mir läuft so
nah so macht jemanden an gelenken linke
als auch produktion einnahmen sollen wir
meine mama verarschen
ich schicke mal ein foto schreiber hat
mir nur gekauft 6000 euro wollte ich nur
sagen mal gucken was zurückkommt okay
für 20.000 gegen den ganzen abend auch
mit dem riemen ton
das ist zu viel das fällt uns auf oder
wie seht ihr das nicht komplett kann
weil man sieht ja nicht mal irgendwie
ziffern oder so also ich würde jetzt
nicht wie spät es ist ja wenn man sieht
was aber ist funkelt und das ist ja das
wichtigste so vielleicht auch um das
video noch ein bisschen interessanter zu
machen ich habe mir gedacht ich schicke
mal kurz meiner mutter ein foto und sagt
ihr habt mir die uhr beginnen für 20.000
euro soll ich die behalten
mal gucken was zu bekommen ist besitzen
jemanden guck mal wie das leuchtet mir
was ich mache hier mit blitz alter
als wertanlage soll ich die behalten ok
hab ich abgeschickt mal gucken was jetzt
vielleicht kommen nicht mehr gespannt
wir machen aber weiter
ein bisschen schade die es mir halt viel
zu groß die muss hier oben an besitzen
so wenn du kannst ja element
herausnehmen was so janke entschuldigung
ist wusste ich nicht wie gesagt ich kann
mir nicht auskommt aus sind hier ist es
eigentlich nichts aber man merkt schon
die verarbeitung hier unten ist
kompletter rotz gut es hat auch nur 3
euro gekostet da kann man auch nicht
erwarten sagen jetzt kommen wir zu
meinem produkt auf das ich mich am
meisten freue und zwar du wirst jetzt
gleich augen machen nur weil es ist
extrem klein heißt ausgänge war es die
kleinen ja ich hätte halt auch gedacht
dass es mindestens so groß ist so so
nacht als werden richtiger orchideen du
denn hin längst aber ist schon geil so
war es früher hatte ich meine zeit da
habe ich ketten getragen so was trage
ich jetzt dann demnächst wieder so ein
stalking alter du bist doch der
heftigste und wenn ich irgendwo im radio
das ist wirklich glaubt man muss man
aufmachen ich nicht kenne das auch so
und hin und der uno flex hatte ich muss
mal kurz selber einmal im spiegel
schauen
also dachte ich wenn ich das nächste mal
irgendwie mal feiern geht oder so dann
ziehe ich diese kette und dann mache ich
es ist nicht sinn meines soll wie das
aussieht balkendiagramm alex wie da
werden übrigens auch alle eis taut
produkte die wir jetzt hier im video
auspacken
wie immer natürlich verlost außer dass
gänger das behalte ich kann's verbot
logik das gibt es jetzt nämlich nicht
mehr
das ist jetzt nicht mehr drei euro wert
sondern schon 100 das ist dein regen
bummler das verlost nicht aber natürlich
die uhr ich weiß hat keinen großen wert
aber hier wird es ihnen herumlief und
jetzt kommen die uhr
die am teuersten war die hat glaube ich
über zehn euro gekostet wie der eiskaut
natürlich was auch ganz meine mama sei
da nicht gelesen naja warten wir euch
auf jeden fall braucht und wir kommen
jetzt zu trauern schon das letzte
produkt weil eben was fehlt noch dieser
kompass fehlt noch na ja das nehmen wir
dann noch im nachhinein auf auch wieder
identisch eingepackt es ist schon mal
nicht das gleiche produkt welche findest
du sie besser aus man muss eigentlich
schon sagen die hier na ja das sieht
einfach aus lösung patek philippe feld
was hat hielt kostet irgendwie auf jeden
fall über zehn euro
es gibt auch schon leute die haben
irgendwie zu viel geld und haben dann
zwei uhren oder aber hier wird es jetzt
bedeutend wenn die original und nicht so
fix elemente hier draußen würde dann
wäre ja deutlich weniger wert du guckst
du am anfang bevor die so machen lässt
naja 60.000 euro oder sowas funktioniert
ja was soll ich dazu noch sagen ich weiß
jetzt auch nicht so also für mich muss
ich ganz ehrlich sagen hat dieses video
jetzt 0 mehrwert so ich habe es halt
gemacht weil es eigentlich eine coole
idee war
und so heißt auch sachen ja gerade im
trend sind und das bayerisch viele gar
habe ich einfach mal bestellt und das
jetzt darum gekommen mehr kann ich dazu
nicht sagen so das ging ja ist auf jeden
fall mein lieblingsprodukt wir warten
jetzt so auf die nachricht von mama und
dann war es das eigentlich auch schon
was jetzt noch markus machen einmal die
produkte abfilmen so für euch weil kann
ja sein dass irgend wer interesse hat an
so was und wie gesagt dann seht das ja
von meiner ins tor
[Musik]
mama hat geantwortet und zwar erst das
was kommt hey bist du denn sicher dass
sie so viel wert ist jetzt schreibt sie
gerade noch wir warten mal ganz kurz ich
bin durch das denn hier nochmal ein und
was wir gerade noch gedacht haben ich
poste mal kurzem eine ins das sowie
einfachste johan micoud watch gewinnt
oder so die kannst du ja nie tragen da
wirst du über fall die richtige mutter
hat es gab zurück aber glänzen
dann sieht man mich überall gut soll
jetzt auflösen der wackel mitnehmen
nicht dass hier unterricht darf nicht
hinter henkel jetzt sieht man es meinen
wir mal noch geschrieben echt sieht
schon sehr echt aus das weiß der
bösewichter nicht und haut dich um
okay leute ganz ehrlich das war es mit
dem video ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen
an die leute die das geld sehen wollten
mehr kann ich dazu jetzt nicht sagen
aber diese kanal morgen mainz nur sehen
wir uns wieder gibt es ein neues video
instagram alex wie und ich gönne mir
jetzt was machen dann machen wir das
machen wir jetzt erstmal club flick
erstmal flex umgehen